the Joe Rogan experience that's a crazy
place Costa Rica's wild man crocodiles
and [ __ ] that was another interesting
place I visited the crocodiles are a
trip man because we were in a boat and
we went on this like sort of tour of
this river system and you go on a tour
the river system I'm watching this
[ __ ] 15 foot crocodile slide into the
water from the bank I'm like [ __ ] and
you see the crocodile slides all over
the banks cuz these these rivers just
filled with crocodiles and so anytime my
kid would come anywhere close to the
railing of the boat like hey hey hey
let's stay over here let's stay in the
middle the [ __ ] away from the monsters I
I met this dude long time ago I don't
remember where he was but we were
sitting around a fire talking about like
bizarre experiences we'd had traveling
whatever he was from I think New
Hampshire and he had a thing like you
and and Marshall go running every
morning he had a thing where he and his
dog would go down to the lake and take a
swim every every day at dusk after when
he got home from work you take the dog
for a swim as a black lab I think and
and he went to visit his brother in
Florida and he drove down there and his
brother was out and when he arrived and
it was around dusk and he's like let's
go first one there's a lake and he jumps
in the water with his dog and they're
swimming across the lake and he hear it
it's quiet right and here's this he's
like what was that
that's a weird sound and then he
realizes I'm in [ __ ] Florida I'm not
in New Hampshire there are alligators
here what the [ __ ] am i doing so he
turns around and starts swimming back
and he's swimming off trying not to
panic and the [ __ ] dog goes are dogs
gone okay now I get it or croc came up
and took his dog never saw the dog again
that could have been him - yeah one of
my favorite alligator stories from
Florida's there was a high-speed chase
got a stolen car and it gets to a bridge
the cops are chasing him guy jumps out
of the car jumps off the bridge gets
immediately literally landed in front of
the alligator you go that often but they
definitely will yeah that's not what
they do
well the crocodiles oxen alligators are
less aggressive than crocodiles and
there are crocodiles in Florida but
they're much less frequent what's the
difference
American alligator is a smaller animal
they have a longer pointy or snout and
they have more exposed teeth an
alligator has a blunt more rounded face
and they they get much larger than
American crocodiles and American
crocodiles are pretty small american
alligators get pretty [ __ ] big so in
Africa - they have Crocs and I'll you
know Africa is just crocodiles just
crying yeah much much more in there Hugh
recive crocodiles yeah they have Nile
crocodile right you see them take those
water buffalo and stuff terrifying
saltwater crocodiles I thought I'd seen
video what you said so I googled it four
different times at least in the last
couple of years this has happened one
guy lost his arm two people died the
Florida thing getting chased by the cops
and ended up getting me finality lower
demand Florida is so wacky that is the
place where all the refuges and the
outcasts they all go to Florida man yeah
yeah more than once I'm sure it makes
sense we jump in the water man you
risking it like they don't just because
alligators don't eat people as often as
crocodiles do in Africa it doesn't mean
that they wouldn't they don't have a
rule ball right like oh that's a person
shouldn't need them they don't give a
[ __ ] if you're a dog or a person or a
kid yeah there was a an alligator ate a
baby at Disneyworld oh I remember that
yeah yeah three years ago yeah yeah
[ __ ] two year old baby playing by the
water that just slides up on the bank
snatch pulls it right under um
[ __ ] [ __ ] that day yeah when I lived in
Florida when I was a kid we lived in
Gainesville and there was alligators
everywhere and I remember one of them
snatched some lady's dog
Jesus Christ I didn't only kill people's
dogs yes he would see them floating
around and they seemed so innocuous
because they did they were almost always
still yeah they very rarely moved there
were signs they didn't want you to feed
him marshmallows people would throw
marshmallows and the alligators would
eat marshmallows and they just don't
want you don't because I said well the
marshmallows yeah I guess yeah and they
would just chew him up and swallow him
some people would throw marshmallows at
the alligators just to see it that was
back when alligators were endangered
this was in the late 70s and they're not
endangered anymore in fact they you
could kill as many of like you can get
it commercial hunting tag for 500
alligators I watched that on that Swamp
People show this is a show about
alligator killers they just killing
alligators you know there's mark the
last Indians to be pacified I hate that
phrase then in the United States the
last tribe to finally give up was the
Seminole in everybody
yeah like after the patchi's and the
Sioux and all that yeah cuz man they
took my weird life yeah far live in the
Everglades
so the Everglades are another thing that
human beings ruined because of white
trash people in Florida because
releasing pythons there's literally
nothing left alive in the Everglades all
the deer are missing all the raccoons
are missing all the all the marsh hairs
gone everything's missing like the
scientists and biologists have done
these surveys of wildlife and the
difference between like 1980 and 2019 is
so unbelievably Stark yeah it's so crazy
and it's all those [ __ ] dorks that
want to keep pets and then they release
them they release them out there in the
wild yeah
[Applause]